Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! the the flash
season 2 just confirmed a new female character
will be joining the show. She'd be like a
really smart Felicity Smoak type character
who might eventually join team flash and be
Grant Gustin's love interest. was part of
the casting call describing her as being spunky
funny intelligent and well versed in science
right away that you they just scream someone
that would be perfect for team flash eventually
whether or not she actually knows the Barry is
the flash when she first meets him the name
on the casting call is Wendy there is a Wendy
Harris in the comics that fits that description
the name could just be a placeholder for someone
more recent in the comics like Patty Spivot
it who also fits the description just like
an arrow every new season introduces new characters
we've already found out about Mirror Master, I've already
done a video about that it only makes sense
that they're going to bring you hero characters
you also have to consider that if Caitlin
Snow is going to become killer frost she won't
be part of team flash anymore leaving a giant
hole so they'll need someone who can take her
place eventually and just to be clear Daniel
Panabaker is a series regular so even if
she does become killer frost she'll still be
in most of the episodes she just won't be
buddy buddy with team flash anymore You also have
to remember that Eddie is gone to so they
could be looking for this new female character
to fill some of his functions at the police
station, Wendy Harris never worked at the police
station the comics she was more of an Oracle
type character but Patty Spivot was the
head of her department at the central city
Police Department they could just be looking
for a character to work with Barry at the
police station who would eventually learn
about him being the flashing and then join
team flash I know they said that there would
be some some romantic things going on between
this new character in Barry at a certain point
was probably can happen first is is she'll
help team flash out with some science related
problem learn berries the flash and then over
time some sort of romantic relationship will
develop and for those that are thinking about
Iris West they did say that she and Barry
were going to be a thing in season to shall
be morning Eddie's death and it was be way
too weird for them to to do anything so if
you're not a big fan of of Barry and Iris
together.don't worry you'll be fine what would
really be fun is if they introduced this new
female character she starts helping Barry
out slowly learns about the flash starts helping
them they have great chemistry together in
that year in the mid season finale Bam she
learns his secret identity the relationship
reaches a boiling point we learned the big
villain is of the season that is typically
what mid season finale's are for its when
the plot boils over in you get a whole bunch
of AutoShip moments both good and bad so now
explain Wendy and Patty's history and the
comics just starting with the the Wendy Harris
proxy she's mostly known for being the Barbara
Gordon Oracle's protege she eventually
took on the proxy name and became a very Barbara
Gordon type character but she actually started
out in the 1970s super friends cartoon She and a
character name Marvin White were like the
teenage sidekicks of the super friends they
had a pet name wonder dog in 2006 they wrote
her and Marvin into the comics as twins think
that they wreck on attempted to make them
biological twins those versions of the characters
became the caretakers of the teen Titans mansion
in the in the wake of infinite crisis they
were super geniuses all you know almost on
par with brainiac probably not quite as smart
as Mr. traffic but you get the idea they didn't
have special powers but they were smarter
than most of the Justice league DC also introduced
the wonder dog character but the twist is
is that he was a demon ended up killing Marvin
and leaving Wendy in a coma later in Barbara
Gordon solo title in the Oracle comic she
wakes up from the coma but she's a paraplegic
so Barbara Gordon has to teach her how to
live without the use of her legs and she becomes
her protege she learns to be a badass
behind a computer and then it eventually is
up helping the Stephanie Brown batgirl and
takes the name proxy relatively speaking though
she is a pretty minor character in the comics
so what I'm thinking is is all take some of
her character traits and give them to the
Patty Spivot character so like that person
on the show that we see will be a combination
of those two people Patty Spivot it also started
out back in the 70s but she she has a much
richer comic book history she debuted in 1977
in this comic called DC special series number
one she became Barry's lab assistant at the
central city Police Department and almost
had the exact same accident that gave him
his flash powers he saved her but then then
later in a daydream he hallucinates her as
Ms. flash like what it happened if I had not
saved her so she became one of the first female
flashes in the DC universe Andrew Kreisberg
engraver Landy did say we be seeing multiple
new flashes in season two is totally possible
they could do a female flash so later in the
comics Jeff Johns used her life during his
run this version of the character had a super
crush on Barry Allen but he ended up marrying
Iris so they entered into this cannot awkward
love triangle in the lead up to flashpoint
she and Barry found a child in a shipping
container that turned out to be the reverse
flash would like the aged himself using the
negative speed force once he was alone with
Patty later he returned himself to normal
age tried to kill her but she was rescued
by the other flashes during flashpoint she
took on the hot pursuit persona so she kinda
got speed forth powers,, not really look slightly
different she and Bart Allen time traveled
to the future almost got trapped by brainiac
she sacrificed herself so that Bart Allen
would get his speed forth powers back so he
can go back in time and savor so she she has
a pretty big arc in the new 52 comics her
character is pretty much the same except that
Barry never married Iris so he and Patty entered
into like a romantic relationship so they
started out like the new 52 flash number 1
as a couple she did not know that Barry was
the flash though but she's working at the
central city Police Department as like the
head of blood analysis so she's a pretty important
character after guerrilla warfare big you
know Gorilla Grodd storyline she learns the
berries the flash in the and they resume the
relationship so right away you know it just
seems that there are a couple of easy things
that the TV show could do to adapt some of
these Comic Book storylines a lot of that
will depend on the context with which she
enters the story like is she going to be working
at the police department will she be replacing
Eddie or will she be a scientist whose helping
team flash out there is so many places that
they could choose to put her whenever she
starts out for me I'd like to see the character
get introduced at the police department so
she gets to know Barry in real life before
she gets to know the flash that said Barry's
lab is really cool but they didn't spend a
whole lot of time there in season one the
spent most of their time filming inside star
labs it feels like if they're going to build
the universe out and Barry needs to have a
life outside team flash needs to have people
that he can go to that are not part of team
flash these are going to be super awkward
with Iris Yorty has Joe but he needs another
female character his age that he can develop
some chemistry with so here's my question
for you guys you where do you want this new
female character to start out do you want
her to be someone working at the police station
who learns about the flash eventually or do
you want her to be a scientist who knows about
the flash right away don't forget the Caitlin
Snow might become killer frost in season 2
if she does that she will be leaving team
flash so they'll be a giant hole that they'll
have to fill so it just makes sense to have
someone working with Barry at the police station
to fill Eddie's role who can later also feel
Caitlin's role remember all this is again
a happen at once this is like all spread out
over the entire season so I think I'm in a
do for my next flash bonus video is talk about
my favorite storylines that I want to see
them do in season two so be sure to subscribe
to get that will try and post it next week
in case you guys haven't noticed I just updated
my YouTube Banner, I'm super excited it's
it's long overdue I needed to change my channel
art a long time ago I included a link to the
Tumblr of the artist that did it he actually
does commissions if you guys want some artwork
like this, I'm seeing Jurassic world tonight
so I'll try to get a review up for that tomorrow
morning while you wait for that you can click
here to learn all about Mirror Master coming
to flash season 2 and his history in the comics
and can click here to learn all about the
Night's King and Azor Ahai on game of thrones
thank you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you tomorrow!